hi my name is Shankar I am writer
producer and director of the job and I'm
here to share 14 things I've learned
from making my second feature film job
with you guys and from courage
our start was most important and number
one is it's not about how much you have
to make a movie it's about what you know
I never went to come school I was
rejected seven times from film schools
and I had to look for alternatives and
YouTube was option for me because
there's so much material out there and I
believe as an artist as a filmmaker you
can always make it work with whatever
you have
filmmakers should know all departments
be producing writing sound acting
editing South Sound editing etc because
it's important and be like one of those
be like Robert Rodriguez
number two is something many filmmakers
just ignore and they tend to forget that
film is a business and it's all about
attitude don't leave anything for
tomorrow if you start a film start a
film set yourself a deadline work worked
towards a deadline and make it happen
don't procrastinate because it's really
bad habit in life and in any business
especially in film let's just be honest
competition is really really hard so
much filmmakers making movies now and
making really good movies and some
people are just born with this crazy
talent in their minds logics can write
amazing dialogues they have those
amazing vision seconds the entire move
it would be before it even was written
on that on a piece of paper it just it's
amazing train yourself compete with
those people because film is competition
again it's a business and you have to
not make a movie that you will like only
you will like and your friends and
family you have to make a move with the
people were like because it's a business
and your film does not belong to you
because your film belongs to the
audience and without audience you are
nobody and nobody will watch the film so
make something people will enjoy know
your audiences because that's a huge
mistake I made many times it's a huge
mistake many people many filmmakers make
I write about three to five scripts and
months and I do it only because I
balance my time it doesn't mean I would
procrastinate or I would just abandon
project I would balance it and still I
have deadlines to follow like when you
go to my IMDB you'll see like I have
ridiculous number of projects in
development and my last year goal was to
finish two future films a year and I
finished two future films a year my 2018
year goal is to finish three films a
year and it will happen follow me if
you're curious but I can promise it will
happen stay focused don't work
number three is casting cast local
actors if you are beginning a filmmaker
like me in my case probably you don't
have a lot of money for casting and to
hiring also casting spaces to green or
to fly actors from another state another
country another cedi accommodate them
here for the casting for the shooting
her sauce so cast locals good attitude
is to go on social media like Twitter
Facebook
also don't forget about drama schools
there are so many amazing actors who are
studying and who are real amazing but
didn't have any connections so give them
a call called school call teacher or
whatever and thousand you're making a
film and if they would be okay with you
posting an ad or something like this for
their students to see and you will be
amazed how many people who get back to
you because those people they are hungry
for acting and you will have a lot of
high quality talent to choose from
number four if your film takes place in
some exotic location and if you'd like
it will be tough to get it or you have
enough money to get it forget it
sit down rewrite get something
accessible then go to the commercial
properties go to the private private
small businesses talk to them many of
them have souls believe it or not and by
talking to them you can negotiate really
low rainy like in my case with a job I
needed huge warehouse and I knew I will
be shooting in London so I called
Pinewood Studios I call Warner Brothers
I called Shepperton Studios and I booked
a stage for shooting day because I
always have deadlines in place a year
before the shooting stars so I called
them I placed my pencil on the stage and
then two months before the shootings at
comeback and all of them and say sorry
we can accommodate you shoot anymore
because we had another commercial and
they booked it for three months I just
went to the classifieds and I found a
couple of places and I just whether I
said hey I'm making a movie would you be
okay if I give you this right for this
many days and I'll make a movie sign
this get your release forms they said
yes and I ended up with hiring a stage
for 11 times less from what I would have
paid in a commercial property so that's
a huge lesson for me unless I have
enough money to shoot something I will
not go to the commercial states every
time the rare film it's like a sand of
the cash Tesco be changing changing
changing so stay away from them
number five do your own props you can do
is not a rotten science depends of
course what you need in my case and your
guns
I had three options one was to go to
film prop houses and rent guns I need
five guns I called them and they asked
for ridiculous amount of money
it was almost entire budget so I had to
look for other options I went to airsoft
sites and I looked into the rank in
aerosol cans again real expensive plus
you need to buy gas to the guns out of
my budget so I want to obey and I just
ordered those cheap plastic guns and I
spray them I made them look real and I
did it all by research in YouTube you
can find so much stuff on YouTube you
just don't even realize what seperates
really low budget movie and higher
budget movie is an amount of time I
spent for pre-production and in
pre-production say choose of the colors
of the costumes of the wardrobes of the
occasions and etc etc in my case I had
to do it all myself because most of my
crew quit because obviously it was no
budget movie so I'm not one of those who
will just quit or postpone the shoot
because once I have deadlines I'll just
work towards it and that's most of me so
be one of those be unstoppable making a
movie
since so many people making movies so
many people have knowledge and have
cameras have equipment ask them to help
you they will help you on your project
and you will help them on their project
exchanging something makes your working
relationship really really good when you
are in an independent filmmaker it's all
about trust because people will just
quit on you and people breaking hearts
and people will just ignore you people
hate you be open to people be nice to
people be honest to people if you cannot
pay somebody be honest with them just
tell them hey I can't pay would you like
if I if I could offer you this or this
don't hold it to yourself don't promise
people to get a thousand bucks a day and
you didn't have those thousand bucks a
day for them when it comes to shooting
and then you will have conflicts and
said and then you'll have arguments you
don't need so be honest from the
beginning
number seven higher good AC ad and DP
those people are hugely important even
on bigger budget overages back to my job
movies so we shot in two days we shot
from 8 a.m. to 8 p.m. and we had to
shoot 60 pages a day believe me or not
we had to shoot 60 pages a day yes it
was one location but there was when you
watch movies there was so much dialogue
you'll be amazed with it and we did it
by having a good ad our ad Silvia she
came along to help me out on day one and
we did about 50 pages on day 2 she
couldn't make it so I had to change my
shooting technique but still because I
was led in so many people so many
projects in Los Angeles I knew was a
dee-nice
move on despite if you have the shot
move on because remember this in
anything you can make completely
different movie so if you miss this
piece of the scene and then this piece
of the scene put you two or three hours
behind and then you didn't have the
engine of the movie that's much worse so
my point is move get your shots don't be
one of those who get 50 takes because
you can afford it unless you have the
budget so be realistic I have your ad
who keeps an eye on the schedule and
keeps an eye on the time because time is
a gold for filmmakers
number eight I know it may sound stupid
but feed your crew don't save on food
like be generous be good to them because
those people and again talking about
independent filmmaking they just
sacrifice their own time and family and
friends to come for couple of days to
work for you to make your movie so at
least be nice to them
Gibbs and brakes gave the food and just
be nice to people don't get aggressive
to people because being rude and
aggressive it's really bad habit in
filmmaking depends where you live but
you'll be amazed how much is on your
phone and you can just order the food
that will get delivered to set very
cheap so do your research that applies
to the pre-production as well but video
crew
do not overshoot give your people breaks
even if it's ten minutes because I've
seen so many times when some filmmakers
should have seen and it looks bad I
think it's bad another one another one
another one fifty takes in everybody's
made each hazard everybody hate each
other and everybody's angry because
there are two hours behind now and that
happens when you work without breaks
because people are human beings and
they're not machines and then your
breaks and even if it's couple of
minutes break it's much much better and
you'll be amazed how much product you
give your casting crew is and they will
thank you at the end of the shoot
number 10 most important plane in
advanced plane in advance this is where
you can make impossible possible scout
for locations people think you need to
be on location to scout for locations I
made this pair from London I never left
London we shut this pair in Scotland on
an island I never been my life that
Island Google Maps go on Google Maps
Google streets you can you can view
everything you can even change time of
the day to see the light now it's
absolutely amazing you can change the
seasons you can change the years you can
see constructions you can see if there
is a building on the way you can see how
it was before that building it's like
amazing and it's it's sad because people
just ignore those toes those toes are
like gold or filmmakers also plenty
shooting dates don't leave it until a
week before where you have just seven
days before the shooting starts you know
how many days you will be shooting for
set yourself and I repeat set yourself a
shooting day and then you go to the crew
you go to the cast and you say hey I'm
shooting this film on these days are you
in or are you out because you don't want
to be too friendly with everyone when
you have an actor or a crew member who
says yeah I'm aim and then when comes
the shooting they have another offer to
have paid projects I have family issues
they have holidays and that leaves you
all alone on your own and it's fine kind
of if it's a crew member because you can
always replace you can work around but
if it's an actor and if it's a lead
actor you are screwed so be strict
plenty of shooting days and set yourself
standards when it comes on set
everybody's professional filmmaking and
especially independent filmmaking
it's not a place where you can leave
something that you last minute because
last minute means our budget and our
budget means two things you will be in
depth you will never finish a movie or
something worse so be really organized
number eleven hard drives I know it
might sound really basic but I lost a
film entire movie future movie because
of the hard drive my first film
outsiders was shot in 2015 in London
England and was shot in eight hours
first day and there was six hours next
day two days 180 minutes of footage done
I was so happy that I put everything on
one Drive just one Drive and because I
was excited I just made my first future
movie I just put it aside for a couple
of weeks I went to Italy to visit my
family I came back to London
and I just packed my bags and I went to
LA back to LA and I could slowly I
started editing and something happened
no idea what water but 50% or even more
the files were gone because I did not
consider hard drives as something really
important and that was really stupid of
me
because hard drive is one the movies
shot once the card that has a footage
been formatted hard drive becomes the
only place where your film is stored so
if it's just one place and if something
happens if it falls down if there is a
fire is there is water damage or there
is loss of the hard drive your movies
gone and now it might be expensive to
some people but do it because hard
drives is it's something that has your
entire movie your time that you spend on
working on particular film and if it's
gone it's gone and you cannot do
anything
number 12 be open to suggestions
keep in mind this your cast in your crew
are there to help you those people that
will not just work harder they will be
on your side to making best movie
possible because they to spend effort
time so makes it flow so they will give
you a lot of suggestions or to you ad
and then your ad will come to you and
say hey how about this so listen because
many times you'll be amazed that it
works really good and you never expected
or assumed something will work suggested
last-minute onset but it does magic
again a filmmaking so listen to your
people be nice to them you know because
they are on your side
number thirteen coming back to
pre-production stay organized stay
focused when you shootin an independent
movie in two days sixty pages a day it's
of easy and things go wrong people get
mad people get stressed people get tired
and by staying calm by staying organized
and by spending enough time in
pre-production you will make it and
you'll be surprised by being calm you
are setting an example to your custom
chrome I will never show to anybody I'm
getting stressed because once my cast
and crew see me being stressed about
something about running out of time but
running out of money
it's very contagious and they will get
this so - and then if you an actor you
are out of character and then if you are
already over time and you are if you are
out of character
you got a Ford to get back to the
character because it's just end of the
movie you will need another day you will
need another location you will need to
bring everybody again to the same set to
finish the movie so show your custom
through example be nice be professional
be prepared or act nice prepared
professional that's what I said what
what happens on set is what happens on
set what happens in real life is
different story
and number 14 and my favorite what makes
or breaks a film editing edit your own
movie technology has changed so much
that you can edit your film on your
laptop
I edited the job myself because my
editor quit on me and I did on 2009
MacBook Pro it's really bad one it's
super slow and we should read 4k it was
complete nightmare and I happen to have
black magic cinema camera that I used in
my teen time and but if you know black
magic design brand you know that it
comes with the which result so I added
entire movie in the which result change
the film to leave only what's important
to the story
don't leave something that looks nice if
you have this amazing shots very
cinematic but it does not belong there
just cut it out cut it out like I said
it took me two weeks go to youtube if
you don't know how to use anything just
tie the name and you will learn it just
it will take you a week five days and
you will be mastered don't listen to
people you need to go to film schools
you can learn this in number of texts
honestly being an independent filmmaker
you have to use everything that's
available to you and you have to make it
forward don't find excuses don't
procrastinate don't leave anything for
tomorrow tomorrow is tomorrow today's
today so do as much as you can today be
organized its I will never say enough be
order has be organized because it's so
important by being organized this is
difference between thumbs that looks
indie and between something that looks
like really big budget movie shot for
nothing
and it's finished and it's out there
because many movies are shot and many
movies are never finished because of
excuse not having enough time but having
enough money not knowing how to do
something I'm not one of those and I
guess other guys if you like this follow
me on Facebook its Facebook / han Corral